for 30 plus that's why to me that's the
way you defend them because his nature
is to facilitate be a pastor
Schroeder Here Comes Maureen
Murray down
the Nugget players come over to help
Murray up as Russell
knock them down the officials are going
to look at it
already bounced back up rather quickly
walked right to the free throw line
here's the first advance that looks like
a good foul going up to try to block the
shot that is a good foul
that's not flagrant
[Applause]
gets the ball then gets the arm it's a
tough ball though
[Music]
and this is the overreaction to me to
every time somebody falls down now then
that's why guys exaggerate and embellish
their Falls because they're always
trying to entice a review that was a
hard fall but not a hard certainly a
hard foul now the only way they might
rule that a flagrant is because there
was the wind up but he clearly wasn't
near the head he was going for the ball
and hit the arm clearly the one that was
to try to disrupt the layup attempt I
think it's a good foul
and I'll say this this is exactly what
all teams need to do if you want to win
in the playoffs
protect the basket and don't give up
easy buckets running on the floor flag
penalty one it'll be two shots
what happened to the game I love this
this we want D'Angelo Russell to do get
out of the way
I think I'm just saying what the reason
they call it is the wind up what wind up
there was a wind up there
there's always a wind-up if you're
trying to block a shot and disrupt it
yeah I mean you're going you can't do it
with a stiff arm
[Applause]
s the ball's extended out to the side
how are you gonna reach it there